andrea is with us in phoenix arizona hi
andrea how are you
hi guys thanks for taking my call um so
i have a quick question
i have a i have been blessed to have a
22 year old who just
graduated asu with his master's degree
um right he did that all on an academic
scholarship
yes yeah right um
so my question is um because of the job
climate right now
he has decided to study for his elsa
and pursue a law degree
okay studying for your lsat when you're
a genius and becoming a lawyer is a
great idea
doing it because of a job climate and
that's your only motivation is a dumb
idea
okay if he wants to really be a lawyer
this kid could be a lawyer but this kid
can be anything he wants to be right
yeah
he can be um he just his his master's
was
in um sports law and business
and there's not really sports happening
right now but that's okay he's got
lots of business and business law under
his belt and he's got a master's degree
with a business function to it and he
you know just because he doesn't operate
in sports doesn't mean he can't operate
yeah okay well that was going to be my
question
so here's the thing i think going to law
school is a great idea for this guy yeah
but only if he wants to be a lawyer not
as an escape mechanism because i don't
want to face
a year with pandemic and audrey sports
are still happening
you do not know but it's the jobs aren't
yeah yeah he's right about that that
job's gone for a while i don't know how
much longer but hopefully a year
but a year from now but i mean there's
there were some great jobs
in his field of study but it's an it was
a nuanced field of study but it wasn't
so nuanced to that it doesn't have other
applications
yeah the the base knowledge he got in
that is is equivalent of an mba
and so he can go into the business world
if that does he want to be a business
person he won't be a lawyer
if i'm being honest he wanted to be the
general manager of the denver bunker
yeah well you probably ought to have
more than one job as a possibility in
your whole life but yeah
um but but conceptually he could he
would like to run the
uh he'd like to be the operational
executive of a forward-facing
consumer-based performance product of
some kind
now there's a lot of those the denver
broncos are not the only one right but
um that's that's not a bad goal that's a
you know great great organization but
you see what i'm saying so does he want
to be in business
or does he want to be a lawyer if he
wants to be a lawyer this kid's
brilliant let's go to law school yeah
okay but he is a brilliant kid but i
think it's just kind of a fallback i
don't know that that's really what he
wants to do yeah sometimes i meet people
who
uh couldn't find a job and so they feel
called to the mission field
and they're not called they're not
called to be missionaries they just
couldn't find a job
and they loved jesus and so they got
distracted
and so you need if you're going on the
mission field you need to be called to
the mission field if you're going into
law you need to be called into law
that's what i would do but this kid's a
kid worth supporting because he's
brilliant
and he's a go-getter he's goal-oriented
he's knocked it out of the park i'm
proud of him and you ought to be too
i just please don't do stuff by default
especially something as expensive
and hard as law school is